(uptempo bass heavy music)
- Hi, I'm Ron Funches.
I'm originally from
Chicago, Illinois.
I'm a Portland, Oregon comedian
that now lives in Los Angeles.
I moved to L.A. about,
almost two years ago.
I was getting
divorced from my wife
and also my comedy
was getting better
and I needed to go to
a place to continue it
so I was like I need to
find a new place to live
either way so I might
as well go to L.A.
I apologize to anybody
who was offended by my use
of the N word in
that previous joke.
I heard a couple of gasps.
And I don't use that word often.
In fact, I struggle
on whether or not
I should use that word at all.
I don't believe we
should ever use that word
to hurt people, but I do
believe we should use it
to shame our pets.
(audience laughs)
Your cat that's an asshole
or a parakeet that thinks
it's better than you.
(audience laughs)
Oh, you think you better than me
just 'cause you can fly?
Nigga, fuck you.
(audience cheers)
I went to community
college for three weeks
and then I was like,
I'm not into this at all
and so I just stopped
going to that.
Like, I hated high
school and then I went
and I was like, oh,
this is high school,
but people can smoke freely.
And now, I hate this even more.
I just never had an interest
in doing anything but comedy.
I would say do what it is
that you really want to do.
You will fall on your face.
It is difficult.
It'll suck.
Some people will be mean to you.
You might be homeless
for a little bit.
But, after that, it gets cool.
It's fun.
I saw a gentleman on a bus
with a tattoo on his neck
that just read, fuck Linda.
(audience laughs)
That guy hates Linda.
Or, he has to remind himself
(audience laughs)
to be intimate with Linda.
Either way, Linda
could do better.
(audience laughs)
(uptempo bass heavy music)